l'ouverture de la bulle atlantique était
attendu déjà aux petites heures du matin
des véhicules faisait la file au pont de
la confédération entre le
nouveau-brunswick et
l'île-du-prince-édouard
on vient tous les ans on aime ça
beaucoup je me suis dit il va moins
noire de monde pascal adam et puis on
directement imposé comme moi l'un de
l'autre côté du pont les voyageurs sont
contrôlées par des agents frontaliers
rejoints un peu plus tard par le premier
ministre denise king qui souhaite la
bienvenue aux touristes il se veut
rassurant alors que des résidents de
l'île ont récemment commis des actes
répréhensibles envers des gens de
l'extérieur de la province
tous les résidents de l'atlantique
peuvent aujourd'hui circuler librement à
l'intérieur de la bulle des quatre
provinces l'exigence d'isolement de 14
jours est désormais levé
comme il aime comme aux habitants
beltane et va rejoindre sa soeur à
halifax qu'elle n'a pas vu depuis plus
de six mois en raison de la pandémie et
elle n'est pas la seule
on est content parce que ça fait un bout
de temps qu'on attend pour aller visiter
notre famille en fin de matinée le
bouchon prend de l'ampleur à la
frontière du nouveau brunswick et de la
nouvelle écosse s'étend maintenant sur
des kilomètres c'est au tour de mylène
de passer on lui demande une preuve de
résidence et si elle a été exposée à la
coved 19 et contrôles frontaliers
demeureront en place jusqu'à nouvel
ordre pour prévenir une deuxième vague
et permettre de tracer l'épidémie en cas
de nouvelles éclosions la seconde qu'on
a le droit de faire quelque chose il
faut le faire sinon s'il ya quelque
chose qui se passe dans deux semaines
qu'on referme les frontières
manqué notre que mylène est finalement
arrivée à halifax et rencontre son neveu
de deux mois pour la première fois
prochaine étape pour les provinces
atlantiques l'ouverture des frontières
avec le reste du canada quelque part
entre la mi et la fin juillet si la
situation reste stable il ne reste que
cinq actifs de lakovic 19 en atlantique
ici nicolas steinbach radio canada à
halifax